This is a 3-D printer
And it’s ink is alive.
Thanks to some helpful bacteria
that can do things like degrade pollutants.
So the researchers called the new ink, “flink”
It’s a Functional Living INK.
With Flink, researchers can make
functional material in any shape.
They can even put one kind of helpful bacteria here,
and a different kind there.
And the printed material is strong enough
to keep printed shapes.
Even complex ones.
Flink also has potential uses in medicine,
When it’s loaded with bacteria that makes cellulose.
With flink, researchers can make cellulose
scaffolds that are useful as
tissue envelopes for organ transplants
And, that may help protect patients
against organ rejection.
The researchers also made a scaffold on the
uneven and varied surface of a doll’s face.
That means the cellulose film
could be used for skin grafts as well.
Without risking the formation of wrinkles or
Creating pockets of material
that could trap contaminants
...and that is something to write home about!